We should tell him the truth
Welcome backeveryone this will be my non-spoilery doctor
strange 2 review there's a whole bunch to talk
about so if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos when
the movie does come out in theaters later this
week i'll post a bunch more spoilery videos the
post credit scenes full movie breakdown everything
there is going to be so much we have to talk
about so please don't post spoilers in this video
if you do get a chance to see the movie early this
movie will blow you away but it is not meant to be
avengers infinity war or avengers end game 2.0
it's not quite as big as some of you might be
expecting even though it seems like it's going to
be huge there are a lot of concepts they introduce
in the movie that are really really huge so it is
a huge movie but not in the way that i think a lot
of people are expecting it to be like avengers
end game was like avengers end game was almost
a three and a half hour movie this movie clocks
into just a little over two hours so it's actually
really really short for a traditional marvel movie
but the basic setup basic synopsis is that doctor
strange is still trying to deal with the aftermath
of what just happened in spider-man no way home
i don't feel like it's a spoiler to say that he
does not remember peter parker like the spell
is pretty self-explanatory he forgets everything
about peter parker but still remembers spider-man
is a character in the mcu they still know that
spider-man is a character web slinging around new
york city they just don't know that it's peter
parker underneath the mask but he's still kind
of reeling from almost breaking the mcu universe
like they just barely save things at the end there
and also finds himself unsatisfied with the way
that avengers infinity war and avengers end game
went down with the whole blip of it all the 1
in 14 million chance in basically sacrificing
iron man's life in order to save the mcu you have
to remember doctor strange essentially asked iron
man to take an l for the entire mcu universe and
he did gladly we meet america chavez and he tries
to save her from what they at first believed to be
an unseen force in the multiverse using witchcraft
to try and take her powers to portal between
universes so she winds up being one of the biggest
macguffins during the movie like hot potato with
america chavez while the movie also serves as
sort of a Wandavision season two unofficially for
scarlet witch this is the closest you'll get to
Wandavision season two who since the end of season
one as implied by that post-credit scene has been
using the dark hole to learn more about what it
means to be the scarlet witch because agatha the
hardness said it was more of a title like a being
of utter chaos magic power one has been figuring
out what it means exactly to be the scarlet witch
and following up on her children's cries billy and
tommy in that post-credit scene the movie also
tries to answer that question too like where did
those cries come from who are those people crying
out are they really her children is something else
going on within those basic ideas the plot is
relatively self-contained like i said it's only
a little over two hours long so there's only so
much you can accomplish in that amount of time
even though the concepts they introduce make it
feel like a much much bigger movie speaking of
which there are a crazy number of cameos using
the multiverse that most of you have seen in
all the trailers most of them won't be spoilers
there are a lot of surprises though the movie
did a lot to set up the next big avengers 5 level
threat for all the other main characters as people
expected no spoilers about what that is i will do
separate videos about that later this week though
but it'll be their next big mega crossover movie
and everyone as you would expect was at the top
of their game benedict cumberbatch one of the
best actors that they've ever gotten in the mcu
so no surprise he kills it no matter what kind of
material they give him he could stand around and
read the phone book and still sound like a really
badass doctor strange elizabeth olsen was also at
her peak in the context of the story as well as
her best performance as scarlet witch in the mcu
so far all the characters in general are meant
to be at the peak of their power so like it's
the most powerful that wong has ever been the
most powerful that doctor strange has ever been
in the mcu the most powerful that scarlet witch
has ever been in the mcu well i take all these
characters everything that's happened to them
recently and just crank the dial up to 11. they
do a really good job with anti-hero wanda during
this movie like she's just a little bit bad but
she's still technically one of the good characters
it's like the parks and rec meme even though they
might go off the rails and do something really
crazy we will still love them all the same for
it the events of doctor strange 2 sort of serve
as the natural escalation of what she was doing
during wandavision and how crazy she got during
that you'll come out of this movie feeling like
she's stomped all over your face but you'll love
her so much that you just keep asking for more
i won't get into the cameo scenes in too great a
detail just because there are still some spoilers
out there but i will talk about the people that
they show clearly in the trailer which is not
a spoiler not a spoiler if it was in the trailer
so with that in mind patrick stewart was amazing
as a version of professor x he was at the premiere
clearly as was hayley atwell but he wasn't playing
a specific version of the character it was just
meant to be a version you've never seen before and
that was true of a lot of the variants as well the
actors actually did a really good job of playing
their own variants playing multiple versions
of the character and making them feel like
distinct different characters same thing with this
multiverse illuminati team with all the different
variants of major characters that you've seen
versions of before in other different productions
or other movies he was great as a version of
professor x in all the fox marvel movies but
long time fans will see a lot of easter
eggs for different versions of his character
from those x-men movies in x-men the animated
series and the same is true for all the other
members of the illuminati if you've been watching
a lot of these marvel productions the tv shows all
these different things for the past 20 years they
pay off and combine a whole bunch of easter eggs
in their brief part during the movie even though
what they do with the characters is really huge
just if you're talking about actual percentage
of the movie they're actually a relatively
small part of the film like i said though i think
they're trying to use them to set up bigger things
in the future they did show captain carter shield
in the trailers and in the poster most of you all
saw my what if videos you saw the what if episode
so you have a pretty good idea of what's going on
with that character it's not the version from what
if it's another version from the multiverse that
we've never seen before but you get the idea
it is a live action haley atwell playing a
version of captain carter she's so fantastic
just like scarlet witch she will wreck you
and you will love it but with them introducing the
concept of the x-men and the other groups that the
team members come from that are a little bit more
spoilery i won't talk about like the other places
that they come from the other movies tv shows
even though they're not a huge part of the movie
they still canonize those characters to the mcu
multiverse so like i said it's a really big deal
for what's coming next a lot of big teams quote
unquote they're getting ready to introduce some
brand new movies during their scenes there are so
many different easter eggs just flying at you left
and right that i will do a separate video for that
later this week after the movie actually comes out
because there's so much stuff that we have to
talk about just in certain parts of the movie
i've already done videos about some of the bigger
cosmic concepts that they introduced in the film
too they pay off a lot of long-running easter eggs
from other movies other really big cosmic concepts
that they didn't have time for in previous movies
like avengers infinity war or avengers end game
without getting too much into that i'll post
some links in the description for the trailer
videos that i did for those things but there are
some really cool really crazy high level concepts
that they've started to get into on moon knight
with things like the mcu gods that we'll see more
of during thor love and thunder like really
really high level characters that you've only
just started to see in the mcu now even though
most of the hardcore fans will just be talking
about all the crazy cameos and they were awesome
so of course you'd be talking a lot about them
all the crazy scarlet witch action is still very
much a doctor strange movie first and foremost
it's about his journey as a character and all the
other characters are just kind of passing through
it on this big adventure that they have with
some of them getting more story than others like
scarlet witch being number two on the call sheet
for obvious reasons and we cannot talk enough
about sam raimi's influence on the movie it was
so awesome that they were able to get him to come
back to the marvel movies to do this the easter
egg circle is now complete because we have tobey
maguire also from spiderman no way home now in
the mcu scott derrickson the director of the first
doctor strange movie had this bold plan to do the
first legit mcu horror movie and sam raimi did
wind up being the perfect person to step in and
complete that thought because they wanted to find
this balance of horror and comedy that he's mostly
known for like all you have to do is watch some of
his evil dead movies army of darkness any of his
other horror movies and most of them are legit
horror movies but with a lot of comedy in them
if you're a long time sam raimi fan especially
the evil dead series like i said army darkness
his other horror films there are a lot of samurai
specific easter eggs in the movie from the way he
shoots movies the techniques he uses his style in
general but there are some macguffins some plot
elements that feel like they're ripped directly
out of a sam raimi movie like the darkhold
the book of the vashanti in the necronomicon
it was true in sam raimi's movies it's true
in the mcu you find an evil book of magic
you know not to read from it just to talk about
the music too because the music was great danny
elfman came back to do it most of you are super
familiar with all of his superhero work going all
the way back to the classic batman movies even
though this is a marvel movie it did feel very
much like danny elfman's music there were even
some jokes that danny elfman wrote into the music
for specific action scenes even though i haven't
talked a lot about rachel mcadams character
in any of the trailer videos that i've done she
got a huge upgrade in this movie her mcu christine
palmer from the first doctor strange movie felt
more like his mother than anything else in this
movie she also plays a variant of christine palmer
working with the illuminati in another universe
that version feels like it's way more fun than the
mcu version even though they do a lot to set up
the future of marvel phase 4 marvel phase 5 like
the really big cosmic stuff and big crossovers
that are happening the movie doesn't go overboard
iron man 2 levels and setting up all that future
stuff without getting into big spoilers i'll
say there's a little bit that you could tie
to what's happening in thor love and thunder
during this but it's really background at most
just to address the post credit scenes be sure you
stay through the entire credits you never leave a
marvel movie early most people have been trained
to not leave yet now there are two post-credits
scenes like most of the recent marvel movies one
of them is more plot based just teasing what's
happening next for all the characters like this
really big crossover that they're heading up to
the other post credit scene is just meant to be a
funny one just calling back to a joke from earlier
in the movie that doesn't really have any bearing
on the larger plot i will do a separate video for
the actual post-credits scenes later this week
talking about what they are teasing like the
really big crossover and what's gonna be happening
next what you do have a chance to see the movie
post all your reactions in the comments below and
please do not post any spoilers until later this
week after the movie comes out some of you also
been asking me about doing merch for my channel
or how to support the channel now youtube is
actually letting you support me by leaving tips
on my videos using that special heart underneath
each of the actual videos is right here they're
supposed to give you guys some special power
ups whenever you do that for each of my videos
so when you try that out let me know if it's
working for you so if you want to support the
channel that's the best way to do it right now
thank you to all of you for all of your support
i might do a longer full spoiler review later
this week so look out for that in my moon knight
finale video we'll post wednesday just like normal
everyone click here for my moon knight episode 6
video i'll update the link as soon as i post
that and click here for all my doctor strange
2 videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!